ثلاثه ايام بعد القصف الذي تعرض له هذا
المبنى في نيبرو بشرق اوكرانيا لا يزال
الاوكرانيون تحت وقع الصدمه بعد وفاه 45
شخصا من بينهم سته اطفال لذا يطالبون بدعم
عسكري اضافي من حلفائهم الغربيين في رساله
مباشره
لبلدنا لكننا نريد المزيد لحمايه ارضنا
وشعبنا لان الكثير منا فقد حياته في هذه
الحرب
باسرع ما يمكن على اسلحه قادره على تقويض
خطط الكرملين الاولويه حاليا هي تامين
صواريخ ارض ارض عاليه الدقه وبعيده المدى
تبلغ حوالي 300 كيلو متر هذه الصواريخ
يطلق عليها اسم وتنتظر كيف الحصول عليها
منذ اشهر من واشنطن باعتبار انها قادره
على الحق الضرر بالجيش الروسي واصابه
الاهداف على ابعد المستويات
يطالبوا بتزويدنا بهذه الصواريخ بعيده
المدى لانها قادره على تدمير مطارات روسيا
بشكل خاص لديهم الكثير من الصواريخ ولكن
ليس لديهم العديد من الطائرات في ذلك من
الاجدر بنا تدمير كل شيء قادر على اطلاق
الصواريخ صواريخ قادره حسبك يافع على
تغيير الوضع العسكري على الارض لكن في
الوقت الحالي لا تزال واشنطن ترفض تسليمها